c'est une sombre histoire qui se répète
en afghanistan l'homme qui repose
maintenant dans ce cercueil ses chats
maraï il dirigeait le bureau de l'agencé
france presse dans la capitale afghane
l'histoire qui se répète car c'est lui
que l'on voit ici ils enterraient en
un de ses collègues tués dans un
attentat et voici ce qu'il disait de son
métier risqué
s'il ya une explosion nous réfléchissons
et nous attendons la deuxième explosion
et quand nous sortons nous pensons que
quelqu'un pourrait nous tirer dessus
c'est précisément ce qui s'est passé
selon une première attaque suicide près
des bureaux des services de
renseignements
et alors que les secours s'organisent et
que les journalistes arrivent pour
couvrir 20 minutes plus tard une
deuxième explosion
le kamikaze s'est fait passer pour un
journaliste explique le chef de la
police de cap c'est le groupe armé est à
islamique qui a revendiqué l'attaqué
maintenant que son pseudo khalifa
n'existe plus à cheval sur la syrie et
l'irak
le groupe se replie sur l'afghanistan en
particulier le long de la frontière avec
le pakistan dans l'est mais aussi au
nord avec la venue de combattants des
pays d'asie centrale
ils seraient entre trois et cinq mille
et ils n'ont pas le monopole de la
terreur les talibans restent très actifs
des victimes civiles toujours toujours
malgré l'horreur le photographe chamarat
et réussissait à capter des couleurs et
des regards il avait six enfants et ils
avaient peur il n'y a plus d'espoir la
vie me paraît même plus dur que sous les
taliban à cause de l'insécurité je n'ose
pas emmener mes enfants en balade
je pense à la voiture piégée au kamikaze
qui va peut-être surgir de la foule
je ne peux pas prendre ce risque pour
eux ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal
[Musique]